Jag skulle säga att det är tvärpa om de större företagen börjar lära sig av de lite mindre.
För det som skyljer dem åt är hur mycket pengar man har möjlighet att stoppa in i marknadsföring.
Eller hur mycket pengar man borde stoppa in i marknadsföring.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dessbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi John Larsson, som dels har Larsson stavat med ett Z.
Är det för att dina föräldrar tyckte väldigt mycket om dansband?
Exakt, nej det där är faktiskt ett eget point som jag har betalt pengar för.
Ja, du tyckte väldigt mycket om dansband.
Ja, exakt.
Dansband är ju inte så stort på Gotland, där jag är ifrån.
Det var väl kanske inte därför.
Däremot så hade jag dubbelnamn och sen så passade jag på att göra mig av med det och gjorde en nystålning i samband med det.
Jag fattar.
Okej, det är inget jag förstår, men jag respekterar det och går vidare för det är inte där vi ska fastna.
Du är ju någon sorts e-handelskonsult och det är ju ett flummigt uttryck, men överlag kan man säga att du styr upp folk som inte riktigt vet hur de ska styra upp sitt företag.
Är det så jag ska förstå vad du jobbar med?
Ja, det kan man väl säga.
För min del handlar affärsutveckling primärt om tre saker.
Det är att ta reda på var det finns outnyttjade affärspotential.
Sen vill man ju omvandla det här till projekt eller konkreta actions.
Sen är det säkert att det genomförs och att någon har en uppföljning på det här.
Din beskrivning låter väl lite ordare än vad jag tycker det är.
Jag fattar, men nu för tiden jobbar du inom...
Vi går igenom hela det sen, men nu för tiden går du in på någon sorts interimsuppdrag eller kommer du in på någon sorts projektbasis eller hur funkar ditt?
Tanken när jag startade upp mitt företag för ett år sedan var att tillföra genomförandekraft och det i projektform.
Det kan ju vara så att man byter ett visst system eller man ska göra jättemycket arbete inom marknaden och behöver temporärt ha mer genomförandekraft.
Sen insåg jag att det där är väldigt bra för köparna och tjänsterna, men en ekonomisk katastrof för min egen led.
Så det har faktiskt varit en mix av interim och mer stru uppdrag.
Och sen så har jag haft baseline, vad ska man säga, affärsutvecklingsprojekt.
Jag har haft med lite folk i podden som har, jag vet inte om de kallar det för byråer, men där de hyr ut personer som gör olika uppdrag eller som kommer in i olika roller och sånt.
Jag är lite fascinerad av det.
Jag har lite svårt att tänka mig att någon skulle kunna komma in här på Gymm Company och så ska de sätta sig in i bolaget på liksom en halv dag och sen ska de driva något projekt.
Är inte det en konstig situation att komma in i och liksom fatta, det är ganska mycket små processer man inte kan eller många smågrejer man inte fattar.
Hur gör man liksom, hur tar du dig an ett projekt?
För min del är det ganska naturligt, för jag har hållit på med andel i tolv år, varav fem som konsult, fyra år som e-handlare och ungefär fem år som leverantör.
Så jag har haft alla de här olika happarna och såklart jobba med konsulter och själva konsulta.
När man kommer in i ett företag så behöver man ju såklart göra en del research och det kan ju ta mindre än en halv dag beroende på vad projektet är, men man behöver ju någonstans förstå affärsmodellen, man behöver förstå värdeöbjudandet och såklart också målgruppen.
Så jag skulle säga att inlärningsperioden kan ju vara väldigt, den kan vara brant, eller i mitt fall, på mitt senaste interimsuppdrag på AC Styling så var den inte så brant för att jag är bilintresserad och liksom varit en del av bilcommunity till 20 år.
Så det var väldigt snabbt.
Skulle jag däremot fått uppdrag på Maja Delores, en hestfrylar, då skulle kurvan peka i.
Då skulle det vara väldigt brant inlärning i att lära känna målgruppen och hur man köper de typer av produkten.
Sen affärsutvecklingsprocessen, den ser ju likadant ut oavsett vilken bransch det är.
Är det så standardiserat eller är det så enkelt?
Ja det skulle jag säga.
Det som många missar är att man tror att ett affärsutvecklingsprojekt är ett one-off-projekt, men det är ju en process som måste ågå i organisationen hela tiden.
Jag ser ofta bolag som gör en satsning, man kanske byter plattform eller går in i en ny marknadskanal.
Inte helt sällan så är det så att innan man gör det här så har man inte bestämt på vilken tid har det stånd man ska mäta ut fallet och vilka kpier man faktiskt ska se på.
Och sen så efter ett tag så går man tillbaka till businesses usual.
Och då tappar man liksom lite det här att hela tiden ta sig framåt.
Och jag tror det är där som många företag har en jättestora utmaning, att man har inte processen och strukturen för att jobba med kontinuerlig utveckling av affären.
Man kanske har det på vissa delar, men inte på affären i sin helhet.
Hur menar du att vi saknar, för jag drar in mig själv i detta då, hur menar du att vi saknar en struktur för att driva det framåt?
Vad betyder det liksom?
Om vi inte snackar konsultspråk utan svennebanansvenska?
Ja, det är lite beroende på storlek av organisation såklart.
Men någonstans har alla företag övergripande affärsmål som man vill uppnå.
Oftast är de finansiella på ett eller annat sätt.
Sen ska de här nere i organisationen i olika tid och omvandlas till faktiska aktiviteter.
När det kommer en vd eller liknande och säger att vi ska öka försäljningen med 20% eller vi ska ha 10 miljoner i vinst nästa år, så blir det väldigt svårt för i princip alla medarbetare på det företaget och omvandla det till handlingar.
Så det är väl liksom den största grejen skulle jag säga.
Bryta ner ett finansiellt mål i vad vi faktiskt måste göra för någonting.
Först på avdelningsnivå men sen också på individnivå.
Och det finns ju ganska mycket forskning på att bara få ett mål, ett finansiellt mål i knet.
Det skapar mycket mer stress än motivation.
Säg att vi har en e-handlare och någon sorts standard e-handlare vi säger som omsätter sådär 50 miljoner.
Så vdn känner sig lite viktig men är inte så viktig egentligen.
Så att de bara, nästa år ska vi växa med 20 procent.
Och så går de ut till alla och säger, kom igen nu allihopa, nu är ni motiverade, vi ska känna tre miljoner till nästa år i resultat.
Och sen händer det inte så mycket mer.
Är det det du menar, att de liksom inte sätter sig ner och bara, ska vi snacka om vad vi behöver göra?
Exakt, väldigt bra beskrivning.
Man skulle ju också kunna vända på det att man börjar från andra hållet.
Okej, nu har vi nästkommande år.
Vilken initiativ ska vi göra?
Marknaden ska göra de här, inköp ska göra de här.
Och sen när man har samlat ihop alla de här initiativen, då kan man se, okej om vi gör allt det här, vad tror vi kommer hända på sista raden?
Vad tror vi kommer hända på tocklang?
Det tycker jag är ett bättre sätt att satsa mål, än att bara dra upp fingret i luften och liksom, hitta på en, för oftast är det en påhittad tillväxtökning.
Den behöver inte alls vara kopplad till hur mycket växer branschen.
Utan det är man bara tänker att vi är 15 professörer i ringet, okej men det finns ingen tillväxt i din bransch.
Då ska jag alltså ta marknadsandelar från en konkurrent.
Okej, vad är det som säger att du ska göra det?
Då kommer vi tillbaka till det här, vilka aktiviteter.
Om du ska ta marknadsandelar eller om du ska fånga ett ökat behov.
Vilket olika strategier du behöver ha där.
Är det inte ganska svårt att sätta sig ner med, jag kommer att ta gymcompanyet som exempel här för att det ska bli halvkonkret typ, men vi är nio pers och hälften jobbar på lagret.
Så om jag frågar dem hur kan vi skicka mer paket så kommer de att säga att de behöver fler folk eller att det är typ det.
Och jag bara menar, om jag går till killarna här på kontoret och säger tja ge mig era idéer för hur vi ska öka och vad ni kan göra mer, det blir jävligt flummigt liksom.
Vem ska ta tag i det där och hur?
Men du belyser ett väldigt vanligt, vad ska vi kalla det, utmaning i e-handelsorganisationen är att jag skulle kanske inte fråga dem på lagret om hur jag ska sälja mer, för att det inte är deras core-kompetens.
Men e-handlare har ju oftast ett väldigt hight organisation och en del har inte ens någon som är ansvarig för försäljningen.
Och det är egentligen helt bizarret.
Du kan ha en butik känt av ACNF i det här med en omsättning på ungefär 50 miljoner, ungefär en miljon besökare i butikern varje år och ingen som faktiskt hade ansvar för att se till att butikern var nice.
Alltså ingen hade det KPI ansvar, men ingen hade heller en sparförsörjning på slevelsen.
Och har du en miljon besökare, då lägger du ganska många miljoner på marknadsföring.
För det blir en liten skevsuddelning där, väldigt ofta.
Och det är för att det löstar uttryck i pengar i en kampanj.
Så i ditt fall så...
Ja men vi har inte heller någon ansvar i för detta.
Nu stänger vi här om en månad på 115 miljoner och vi har ingen som är ansvarig för försäljning.
Jag vet inte ens vad den rollen ska vara.
Ska vi ha någon som är ansvarig för butiken?
Var det en hemsida liksom?
Hur krångligt kan det vara till?
Ja hur krångligt kan det vara exakt.
Men det är ju de som har blivit helt arbetsliv åt att lära sig e-handelshantverket och beteende psykologi online är ju betydligt mycket mer komplex än vad det är i en fysisk butik där produkten som står i ögonhöjning på yllan är den som kommer att sälja mest automatiskt.
Hur mycket hatar du e-handelsgrundare som driver bolag som att såhär, ah, det här är en hemsida, gå in och klicka någonstans, det är ju en stor grön knapptryck på den.
Blir du frustrerad när du ser hur mycket dålig e-handel det finns därute?
Ja, jag hatar väl ingen grundare, men det är klart att man kan bli frustrerad över att det finns väldigt mycket dålig e-handel.
Och det är ju återigen för att man inte har den här processen att jobba med kontinuerlig förbättring av sin köpupplevelse framförallt.
Vilka gör detta bra då?
Har du något exempel på företag som du tycker är duktiga?
Jag fattar att det är svårt för man kanske inte ser allas interna processer, men har du träffat några som du tycker gillar hur de snackar kring detta?
Det är väldigt svårt att avgöra hur många som jobbar med strukturerad A-B-testning eller konverteringsoptimering som vi pratar om i det här fallet.
Men jag kan väl ta Amazon som ett exempel eller att de ger framgång i hur mycket lärdomar de kan ta och hur mycket tester de kan ha igång samtidigt.
Sen tycker jag att Amazon-siten är ingen fröjd för ögat, men vi kan ju ganska enkelt koppla den till Apotia som inte heller är någon visuellt tilltalande köpupplevelse så det är inte det som är meningen.
Du ska gå så snabbt som möjligt från behov till att hitta din produkt och avslut.
Kan man dra en jämförelse rakt av dig?
Jag tänker att både Apotia och Amazon är ju på något sätt en stor databas för rena produkter medans ett varumärke som du sa Maja Dolores här, det är lite mer än att du ska skapa en viss känsla och en viss...
Ska de jobba på samma sätt?
Apotia ska ju bara vara snabbt att söka för.
Det som många varumärken gjorde fel när de började med e-handel, det var att de gjorde det som en visuellt bylt fönster.
Oftast så tog man in någon designbyrå som aldrig hade designen i e-handel och sen så gjorde man den visuellt tilltalen.
Sen började man fråga sig själv, varför man inte sålda någonting.
Sen i takt med att man har fått lite mer kunskap och förstått i handelsaffären lite bättre så har man börjat design och köpupplevelser som får mina mer om en vanlig transaktions e-handel.
Men det är klart att det är ett utvarumärke så vill du kanske ha en mix av de här två.
Det beror lite på vad din affärsstrategi är och säljer mycket i egen kanal eller ska den egna kanalen framför allt vara inspiration och sen så ska försäljningen på elviga åter försälja det.
Det finns ju inget slätt eller fel utan det är ju egentligen affärsstrategin som bestämmer vad som är vettväg framåt.
Nu känns det som om jag bara har hållit på här med snabbfrågor i typ femton minuter.
Jag tänker om man sitter och lyssnar på detta nu så kan man liksom luta sig tillbaka.
Nu går vi in i ett lite mer behagligt John-dialog här.
John, egentligen första frågan.
Vem är John?
Ja, han är ju en Gotlands kille som kom i kontakt med E&R ganska tidigt.
För att butikssutbudet på Gotland är väldigt begränsat.
Så när man var femton, sextan så åkte man till Stockholm över dagen.
Man lade på sig en massa arkeder och sen åkte man hemma i kvällsbåten.
Så när E&R kom så var jag ganska snabbt på den.
Och sen så blev det mer ett arbete.
Men det är inte så mycket jag som person, utan som person så är jag väldigt mån om att hela tiden utveckla mig själv.
Det gäller både arbetslivet men också i form av fysisk prestation, olika sporter.
När jag tycker om att se nya saker, har väldigt lite flygskam, så vet jag att 6% av all rotsläpp i världen kommer från transport.
Så det kanske inte är där man ska stå med det stora pekfingretet, om man kanske ska titta på vissa industrier.
Det är väl min fritid skulle jag säga, att lära mig nya saker, utveckla mig själv och sen se nya saker.
Väldigt nyfiken.
Vad menar du med att du har fysisk prestation?
Vad är det du försöker hoppas högt fram lite?
Det var mittsatt att säga att ta hand om mig själv.
Sen om träningsformen är styrketräning eller tennis eller löpning, det är lite strömsamma men för att imponera lite grann för det så har jag gått en personligt utbildning i USA, jag har gått med pastodivarutbildning, jag har jobbat som PT.
Tidigare innan jag fick min ryggskada 2006 höll jag på med idrott på elitnivå.
Det har jag alltid funnits med mig, även fast jag är en förtidspensionär på det området, så lever jag fortfarande lika hälsosamt som att jag skulle ställa upp i fotbolls-VM i sommar.
Jag fattar, är du ett A-barn?
Det är jag verkligen.
Var du även duktig i skolan?
Ja, men jag var samtidigt också lite lat.
Eftersom jag hade lätt för att lära mig så lade jag väl den tid som behövdes, men inte så mycket mer utan mitt fotbollsbargo ner i drott.
Jag köper det, känns som det ofta blir så.
Man liksom sailar igenom lite grann, och så wastear man 18 år, eller vad man nu...
Ja, fast ska jag vara helt ärlig så tycker jag oavsett om jag hade fått MBG i alla MNN, så hade jag studerat jobb på arbetsliv eller liksom det du läser på gymnasiet tycker jag faktiskt är liksom, om du inte läser en bilmekanikerutbildning eller någonting sånt där så är det ganska oviktigt för vad du gör sedan.
Vi kommer till arbetsliv då.
Du har ju haft lite olika roll där i lite olika bolag, men en grej som jag tycker går igen, och du får rätta mig om jag är fel, är att du verkar jobba med lite osexiga bolag.
Jag menar det med all kärlek eller liksom katalogbolag eller vad jag skulle kalla det.
Så förstår du vad jag menar?
Reservdelar eller bildelar eller...
Tycker man inte om bilar så är det klart att det inte är den sexigaste branschen.
Det förstår jag också.
Sen så är det ju så att även om utåt sett de här företagen kanske framstår som katalogbolag för att de upplevs ganska omoderna och sitter på väldigt tekniskt gamla plattformar, så har de ju ändå en aggregerad omsättning på närmare 1,4 miljarder, 1,5 miljard.
De vet ju hur man säljer saker och det är ju att man vågar eller har möjlighet att stoppa in väldigt mycket pengar i marknadsföring.
Jag underskattar inte deras förmåga att bli stora.
Alltid när e-andlare säger att vi växte jättefort från 5 till 10 miljoner, så är det så här att det finns.
Som du sa, apotea.
Omsätter lika mycket som de 50 största inspirationsvarumärkena på nätet.
Det är inte där pengarna finns, utan pengarna finns ju i katalogbusiness, som jag kallar det.
Folk får bli sura om det.
Men jag menar liksom, man går in på en hemsida, man skriver i sitt registreringsnummer och så kommer det upp 800 produkter som matchar till den.
Och så får jag den produkten jag vill ha och så är livet klart så.
Vi som jobbar med Eanderlund, när du har jobbat inom den branschen, är du lite färgad av den, att allting ska vara uppstyrt på ett visst sätt.
Du nämnde Amazon som bolag här tidigare.
För mig är det ju svårt att se Amazon som, jag vet att de är skitstora, men de är ju inte ascharmiga i sin design eller?
Om vi går tillbaka till varför jag hamnade inom de här osaxiga produkterna, så är det väl för att jag har en total avsaknad avdrivkraft av att sälja prylar bara på säljandets skull.
Det var också en av anledningarna till att jag blev kvar på en performance pyro bara i fyra månader för att jag kunde inte motivera mig själva.
Att bara sälja en massa skit, om vi får säga det så.
För att ingen i Norden behöver mer prylar, så även om produkten i sig själv, däck eller fälgar eller vad det kan vara, inte är så rolig så är det ingenting man köper om man inte måste ha det.
Och det känns bättre för min del.
Att inte försöka driva försäljning i en sånt wish-kopi av butik.
Så det är inte svårt med andra att driva försäljning.
Det kan i princip vem som helst göra det.
Utmaningen är ju att göra det med en lönsamhet.
Samtidigt som man skalar upp organisationen.
Och går ut på nemarknaden.
Det är ju det som är den verkliga utmaningen.
Jobbar du mer mot sådana kopier än mot att driva...
Du har väl jobbat med marknadsföring?
Ja jag har jobbat med marknadsföring väldigt länge.
Vad är den stora skillnaden i att jobba med marknadsföring mot produkter som liksom är behövda produkter.
Som ifall jag ska köpa en fälg då eller en förgasare, jag vet inte.
Och jämfört med produkter som är på något sätt bara önskvärda som bygger mer på att det här hade varit kul.
Ja alltså det kräver en liten annan strategi.
Och det är faktiskt svårare än man tror att jobba med logisk köp.
Visst, du sitter och skapar ett behov, men du måste vinna i exakt för att ögonblick.
Så säljer du däckbyteln eller en förgasare som du gav exempel på i det här fallet, så behöver du vara top of mind så att kunden tänker på det när behovet uppstår.
Du behöver vara en pålitlig aktör och du behöver vara enkelt.
Så du behöver ha både en mental och krisisk tillgänglighet.
Och så behöver du ladda varumärket med förtroende.
Kontra ett retail-varumärke, sen när man kanske mer behöver ladda varumärket, man vill vara en del av det community.
Det är en väldigt stor sjunnad kan man säga.
Hur gör man det rent praktiskt?
Tenderar inte det bara att gå in?
Gör inte alla bara ungefär samma sak?
Eller kan du ge något exempel på hur det spelar ut sig själv?
Ja, om vi tar ett exempel just när det gäller däckbyte som är en tjänst.
Du vill få det löst, men du vill också veta vart och när du kan få det löst.
Sen vill du också känna någon typ av trygghet att den som löser det här behovet åt dig, gör det på ett bra sätt.
Utmaningen kan ju vara i den branschen, att däckbyte gör man två gånger per år.
Så att lägga top of mind på den mentala inköpslistan, det kräver ju att du anpassar din marknadsföring och jobbar väldigt intensivt i vissa perioder.
Just när däckbyterna ska ske, om du nu är en verkstad som enbart gör däckbyte.
Är du en verkstad som gör allt typ av bilservice, men också däckbyten, då kan du se till att vara top of mind året runt.
För bilen kan ju gå sönder när som helst eller ha servicebehov.
Det vet du ju inte riktigt.
Där blir ju den stora utmaningen att hur stor del av de pressumtiversköparna, det vill säga all bilägare, är just nu, utepå marknaden, för att köpa det du erbjuder.
Det är en ganska liten anledning, för att om man pratar om ungefär 5-10 procent.
Och då kan det ju bli utmanande att nå dem på ett kostnadseffektivt sätt.
Men jag förstår lite grann, jag bara tycker att alltid när man pratar om att man ska nå ut till kund, eller man ska bygga varumärket så tenderar det att klumpas ihop.
Allting känns ganska likt.
Man tänker att man ska vara lite unik och man har sina behov.
Men om vi tar det här med att byta däck som exempel, där skiter jag i fullständigt i vilket community jag är del i.
Jag vill ju veta att de får mina däck bytta inom 20 minuter och att de är öppna och att de kan lösa min modell.
Det är ju en väldigt tydlig kopistyrd verksamhet medan vissa andra produkter inte är så.
Så jag kan köpa att deras site kan se väldigt annorlunda ut.
Och jag kan köpa att deras marknadsföring kan se väldigt annorlunda ut.
Ja, så är det ju.
Men i mitt fall så tycker jag att bara för att man erbjuder en tjänst som nödvändigtvis inte ingår i ramverket för hur en retail i handel ser ut.
Då ska du ändå ha en hel del jämförbar komponenter för att göra det enkelt för kunden att navigera.
Det är klart att idag finns det en best practice på hur en e-handel ska se ut.
Flödet mellan PLP och PDP och Kassa.
Det finns en best practice där.
Och den behöver du inte fråga varför du har en produkt eller en tjänst som inte är exakt som den här t-shirten eller filmjalken eller vad det nu kan vara.
Så att du kan fortfarande ha med dig att jag designar min upplevelse så som de stora massan av människor är i banan att interagera med en digital lösning.
Sen så behöver du såklart anpassa den.
Ska du ha däckbyte så ska du kanske ha tidsbokning eller du ska ha en kart i den närmaste stationen eller en massa andra tekniska lösningar runt en kling.
Men ramverket kan vara liknande.
Alltså, på något sätt så, jag vet att jag klumpar ihop de här, kallar dem för katalogbusiness och nu har det blivit så.
Nu blev det det ordet som får göras här och det heter säkert inte så.
Men det är ju de som är stora.
Vad kan vi andra e-handlare lära oss från deras business?
Vad gör de mycket bättre än vad vi gör?
Vi som tänker, ja jag ska skapa en spännande annons här som folk ska gilla och så tror vi att det är hela arbetsdagen.
Finns det någonting som de här riktiga maskinerna gör mycket bättre än vad vi gör?
Jag skulle säga att det är tvärtom.
De större företagen börjar lära sig av de lite mindre.
För det som skiljer dem åt det är hur mycket pengar man har möjlighet att stoppa in i marknadsföring.
Det är liksom den eller hur mycket pengar man vågar stoppa in i marknadsföring.
Små, mindre företag har oftast betydligt bättre kundtjänst.
De har betydligt bättre koll på vissa typer av kopier för att de har det behöver inte vara för att man är liten men om man är relativt nystartad av de modernare tekniska lösningar och en modernare datastruktur.
Så mitt råd till de som vill bli stor det är såklart inte att fokusera på en enskild kampanj men att lyfta upp det som man får av att handla av en mindre aktör och det är ju oftast uppmärksamhet och sördis.
Det är lite samma sak.
Så jag skulle säga de två.
Så det är lite tvärt emot.
Ja men jag gillar det, jag gillar det.
Det är lite skönt på något sätt.
Men vad är det som gör?
Är det för att man försöker mer spela på de storas planalva?
Man försöker jämföra sig med dem.
Man säger att vi har snabb frakt som att inte alla har det typ.
Ja det behöver man väl inte ens säga att man har.
För om du ska bli större än aktören som är störst, så innebär det att du behöver lägga mer pengar än dem på marknadsföring.
Det steget kan ju vara väldigt stort.
Så det är klart att du måste dela upp det här under ganska många år.
Men du måste ändå ha den förståelsen att ska jag bli störst så måste jag ha mest synlighet.
Då får man ju börja se att det går att ta fram ungefärliga siffror på hur mycket pengar den största aktören lägger på marknadsföring.
Sen kan man se hur långt ifrån man är där och hur mycket pengar man behöver ha för att faktiskt fundera så mycket pengar.
Okej, absolut att man behöver komma i kapp med marknadsföring, men behöver man liksom, hur behöver man sätta varumärke i?
Är det ett uttjatat ord eller handlar det, bygger man bara varumärke genom att synas eller att sälja mer eller behöver man sätta det mot konkurrenterna i den tillväxten?
Kan du bara reflektera lite kring varumärkesbygget i det där?
Att du har en stor omsättning innebär ju inte att du har ett omtyckt varumärke eller att ditt varumärke uppfattas på det sättet som du vill.
Det finns en skillnad mellan brand-image och brand-profile.
Det vill säga att du har en profil om hur du vill uppfattas men hur målgruppen uppfattar det, det kan ju vara väldigt stor skillnad där.
Tyvärr är det väldigt få som gör marknadsundersökningar och ens tar reda på hur man blir uppfattad av sin målgrupp.
Det jag skulle väl säga om jag tänker en mindre aktör och en stor aktör är, det är lite beroende på vad du säljer också, hur viktigt varumärket är.
Som du nämner om man bara vill ha en tjänstlöst, om man vill köpa däck eller om man vill göra någon annan tråkig sak, så är varumärket inte alls viktigt.
Men för en del så är det varumärket en väldigt stor del av ens hur man ser på sig själv och ens själv bild.
Om vi tar bilar ut, ett väldigt bra exempel.
Jag är ju en BMW-kille.
Jag har ju väldigt svårt att se mig själv köra.
Det finns jättemånga andra bilar som jag tycker ser bra ut, men som jag samtidigt har väldigt svårt att se mig själv köpa av olika anledningar.
Till exempel en Porsche.
Då känns det som att jag är någon direktörsgubbe och det är inte alls hur jag ser på mig själv.
Tror du att du har samma bild om dig själv då som vi andra som ser dig köra runt i BMWen?
Vi har ju en bild.
Ja och det här är ju lite, jag tror kanske att jag är lite speciell här, att jag köper inte en bil för att man annans tycker att den är fin.
Eller jag har generellt ett näsning till obefintligt bekräftelsebehov på det sättet.
Jag månade att andra ska tycka att min t-shirt är snygg eller vad det nu kan vara.
Men för vissa människor så är det ju väldigt viktigt att man har en viss typ av statusmarkärer i form av varumärke på sin tröja eller skor eller vad det kan vara.
Men om vi går tillbaka lite i tiden så varför finns varumärken?
Det är ju för att separera olika produkter från varandra och göra det enklare för köparen att ta beslut.
Och merparten av alla våra köp och slut går ju på automatik.
Så är det ett nytt varumärke som ska in i en kategori där det finns en aktör som har väldigt stor marknadsandel.
Så behöver du ju inte ett sätt att erbjuda någonting bättre än dem men du behöver också bryta ett invant köpeteende och det är ju det som är det svårare här.
För att vi människor är ju van i djur.
Och vi måste ta väldigt mycket beslut på automatik för att annars orkar inte hjärnan med.
Och där tror jag att vi blir latare och latare faktiskt.
Det är mitt stora mål med Gymm-Kompaniet är att bli fallback-varumärke.
Alltså om du ska in och köpa gymm-utrustning och du är såhär vad fan ska jag handla?
Jag handlar på Gymm-Kompaniet.
Du vet såhär, det ska bli det här baseline-varumärke för att man det är det man tänker när man hör gymm-utrustning.
Såsom jag tänker, antingen åker jag till Ikea eller så tar jag ett aktivt val och åker någon annanstans.
Ikea är liksom inte det aktiva valet, det är bara något.
Det är bara dit man åker för att man börjar titta där typ.
Jag vet inte, eller man börjar googla för att man börjar googla.
Jag måste aktivt gå någon annanstans när jag ska göra det, för det är bara weird.
Nu kollar vi folk.
Men jag fattar, har du någon, detta är en svår fråga kanske, men du får många svåra frågor idag, så vi kör på med det.
Finns det någon vinkel som du skulle säga är bättre att komma in i om du ska gå in och utmana andra varumärken?
Är det liksom, hej vi har bättre service och bryr sig folk om det eller är det hej vi är små uppstickare, ja det går folk igång på eller hej titta vi är trendiga.
Alltså finns det någon vinkel som du märker, de märker få lite traction ofta.
Det är såklart lite branschberoende, hur viktigt det är att vara snabbrörlig eller göra saker på ett annorlunda sätt.
Men jag tror att för att differensera sig så behöver man ju såklart se ut och prata på ett litet annat sätt.
Men man behöver ju också kunna ha bakomliggande processer och strukturer som fungerar på ett annat sätt.
Och det är väl där med en nystartade företag har ett väldigt stort övertag på att lägga sig.
Vi kan ju ta Tesla som ett exempel.
De har en helt annan produktionslinan än vad ett klassiskt bilföretag har som har finnat sig under 20 år.
Och även om du har kompetensen så innebär inte det att du tar rätt beslut.
Vi kan ta Kodak som ett ännu bättre exempel.
De var världsledande på kamera och sen så försvann de i princip.
Och Kodak tog redan på 70-talet fram den första digital kameran.
Så de hade ju kompetensen.
De var först i världen med en digital kamera.
Men de var ju så inokörda på att deras affärsmodell och deras intäkter skulle genereras från filmrullar.
Så de valde att inte lansera den här digital kameran.
Sen kom en uppsked av tillverkare som gjorde digital kamera.
Och Kodak gick fram och var överlegsen marknadsledare till att ditt insid blir helt utraderad.
Och det var ju för att dels man vågade inte iterera på sin affärsmodell och man hade inte en struktur för att inkorporera nya tjänster eller produkter i verksamheten, utan man gjorde det som man alltid hade gjort.
Och det är det som är den stora fördelen med mindre om ni instämtade företag är att de kan sätta snabbare processer i strukturen.
De här gamla är liksom fast i någon typ av såhär har vi alltid gjort tänk och när man ska ändra någonting så tar det väldigt väldigt lång tid.
Det vill säga man blir trög rörlig.
Och här kommer vi verkligen se med AI att det är många såna här gamla företag nu, de behöver inte vara så gamla som kommer att redigera sig ut helt.
Bara att de inte kommer att applicera AI tillräckligt snabbt eller kanske inte alls.
Kan du känna en orö över din egen roll?
Alltså affärsutvecklare och vad vi ska säga e-handelskonsult eller kan man inte bara dra in AI-verktyg och så får man samma svar eller samma tjänst?
Rent krast så kan man ju bygga en AI-agent som kopplar ihop din köpdata med en besöksbeteende, med en finansiellt utfall, med all din marknadsdata från alla olika kanaler och sen så kan AI ingöra analysarbetet och den kan uttäcka fram en inkluderationsplan.
Den kan ju även koda och bygga de här förändringarna och genomfölja upp dem.
Så ja den kan ju göra allt men jag tror att det är ganska långt bort innan företag har byggt en sådan här agent.
För att det är sallan tekniska verktyg som begränsar organisationer vid kompetens och genomförande.
Det vill säga man har inte strukturen att jobba med hög förändringstakt.
Och det är det som skiljer framgångsrika företag från mindre framgångsrika.
Det är därför det kan komma att nystarta ett företag och jättemycket marknadshandelar och sen till slut bli marknadsledare.
Just för att man har ett helt annat arbetssätt.
Och det tror jag kommer att bli väldigt, väldigt synbart i närtid.
Så svaret på en fråga är, ja, i min roll så den mänskliga faktorn kommer ju, den kommer fortfarande behövas för vi behöver ha någon som är kompetent nog och kan bygga ihop alla de här dataströmmarna och säga åt A-Inn vad den ska göra.
Men sen så tror jag det är ganska långt bort innan man faktiskt vågar låta A-Inn vara helt autonom.
Liksom ta alla de här besluten åt A-Inn.
Så det kommer nog bli ett litet annat sätt man gör det på framöver.
När du går in i ett bolag, skulle du kunna ge oss lite pointers vad du brukar, finns det några uppenbara fel som ganska många gör eller finns det några, du sa ju till exempel tidigare här att man kanske inte har en process för att driva affären framåt, men kan du ibland bli förvånad över vad som saknas och vad du tycker att folk borde lägga in, eller vad folk ofta gör för misstag, kan du bara reflektera lite kring företag och vad vi gör bra eller vad vi gör dåligt?
För det första är det väldigt lätt att som utomstående komma in i en organisation och tänka så här, varför gör de inte AB och C, det här är liksom basic saker.
Men sen så inser man ju att det är oftast väldigt tajta organisationer och man är så kostnadsmedveten att man inte väljer att anställa mer resurser och mer kompetens, utan det är ett fåtal personer som får göra allt och då har man en prioritetsliste och dagligen så prioriterar man bort saker.
Så att man får vara lite ödmjuk inför det.
Och det innebär ju att man kan fånga upp saker som är väldigt lätta att förändra, men som personalen eller organisationen inte har tänkt på för att man är så fokuserad på att ta sig igenom den dagliga arbetsbördan.
Jag tror att väldigt många e-handlare skulle ha storvinning av att antingen ta in en konsult, för det kan vara ett väldigt bra sätt att ta in en konsult som ska jobba med de här delarna och sen kan det arbete som konsulten gör sen bli till en rollbeskrivning för en framtida anställning.
Men att svaret på din egentliga fråga är väl att det man oftast upptäcker är ju att det saknas egendeskap.
Det är väldigt otydligt med dem som gör vilken KPI eller att man inte jobbar mot KPI, rent generellt.
Och sen skulle jag säga att man kanske inte riktigt har strukturen eller processen som är skalbar för att du kanske omsätter 100 miljoner idag men du vill omsätta 300 miljoner.
Okej, men då måste du kanske redan idag börja bete dig som att du omsätter 3 miljoner.
På minus fyra senaste arbetsplatser är projektledningsverktyg för att effektivisera arbetet men också göra tydligare vem som är iägare.
Speciellt när man är inne i andel idag med en lite mer gedigen organisation så har du ett marknads-
team, du har ett sälj-team.
Så du har ett kunstnärs-team.
Och alla de här behöver interagera med varandra och dela data och ge erfarenheter.
Tyvärr så är det väl ganska mycket så att man jobbar fortfarande i kilos.
Och det har jag märkt i organisationer oavsett om ni är fem personer eller femtio.
Så blir det inte bara ett jävla blajt om alla ska hålla på att dela information med varandra hela tiden.
Ska jag som sitter på marknadsföringen, ska jag sitta och lyssna på vad folk klagar på hela tiden?
Nej, nej det var verkligen inte så jag myndade.
Det blir en jävla spämad tråd bara känner jag.
Ja, nej men det är ju inte så jag tänker att informationsdelningen ska gå till.
För det första ska man bara ha information som är av användning för föringsarbetsroll.
Men om vi utgår från att du är ett produktföretag så kan vi utgå från produktredelsen och den börjar någonstans med att en inköpare tar beslut om att köpa in den här skivstången.
Skivstången kommer till lagret på inleverans.
Då behöver någon stark kille bära upp den här förmodligen eller ta in den i fotosturgan.
Någon kanske lite mer marknadsorienterad människa behöver fotografera den här.
Vi behöver skriva en produkttext, den blir upp på sajten, den blir marknadsföras i olika kanaler.
Här har vi kanske fem-sex olika personer som ska arbeta med den här produkten.
I olika pågällande har du ett projektledningsverktyg så kan du se till att alla vet vart i den här processen produkten befinner sig någonstans.
Sedan behöver du också, jag har inte minst någon som är försäljningsansvarig men om du har köpt in den här skidstången så vill du kanske se att man hör att försäljningen gått de två första månaderna.
Nej den har inte gått bra.
Okej men hur mycket pengar har vi lagt på för cyko-säljarna?
Vi kanske inte har lagt några pengar alls.
Okej men då gör vi en kampanj mot skidstång och sen så ser vi vad det ger.
Det är ett typ exempel på när det är väldigt många olika roller som är delaktiga i en ganska vanlig händelsesedja för att lägga upp ner produkter.
Sen så tycker jag kanske inte alls att det är det inköpare som ska sitta och liksom om vi köper in de här, vi får så bra pris eller ohär, kan vi spara pengar så vi köper in den här?
Utan det blir det här inifrån och uttänket istället för att tog in bara vad är det marknaden verkligen vill ha nu?
Vad är det man efterfrågar?
Ja, nu vill du efterfråga marknaden skistång med två handtals för att folk har fått så dålig rörlighet i axlarna så de kommer liksom inte bakåt och kan greppa en vanlig skistång.
Okej, då är det det vi ska fokusera på.
Men oftast är man alldeles för bekviem för att samla in den här insikten.
För ett riktigt bra värdebjudande, product market fit, det bygger på att du har djupgående insikter i vad målgruppen vill ha.
Vad är deras utmaningar, vilka är de behov de vill få löst.
Det här förändras ju vid tiden, speciellt inom treanning.
Det kommer nya trender hela tiden.
En dag är det hit, en andra dag är det 3x och sen är det crossfit.
Och det ställer ju olika krav på utrustningen.
Jag tänker också att det är det som är en av svårigheterna.
Jag har ingen fråga på detta.
Det här är bara någon sorts weird reflektion.
Men när man är ett litet företag så är det väldigt enkelt.
För då sitter man själv och svarar på alla kundmail.
Och då märker man egentligen vad behovet är och då köper man in det för man är själv inköpare.
Och sen ju större man blir desto mindre interaktion har man ju ofta med kunderna.
Då kanske man löser inköp eller ekonomi eller något sånt där.
Och då blir det liksom, jag kan se att många gör det föräldet både hos oss eller i branschen.
I stället för att köpa in produkter som kanske kunderna faktiskt efterfrågar, så blir det i stället att man tar produkter som man vet säljer bra, som man redan har, och så justerar man någon jävla färg på den.
Eller liksom någon ring på den.
Och det är liksom inte det kunden efterfrågar.
Men man själv har lärt sig någon sorts, så här, vi har svarta byxor, och om de säljer bra, då kanske vi kan sälja svarta byxor med två fickor i stället.
Och de kommer också sälja bra.
Men det är liksom inte det kunden har efterfrågat.
Men de kommer antagligen sälja bra, för att de tar, men till slut dör det där ut.
Det blir liksom inget nyskapande i det.
Jag bara tycker att det går igen i beteendet.
Och det är också en svårighet i att skala upp för att man slutar lyssna på fördagen.
Men innan du reflekterar över det, för jag har en annan fråga som jag vill fråga.
För du sa att man ska ta in en konsult.
Eller att man skulle kunna ta in en konsult.
Det tycker jag är ett svårt beslut att ta.
Du får gärna sälja in dig själv såklart.
När jag sitter och tänker såhär, fan vad vi är dåliga på detta.
Då blir ju min tanke någonstans, ska vi ta in en konsult?
Vad fan ska den konsulten göra?
Och så kommer den vara där och ha lite åsikter under en månad och sen försvinner den konsulten.
Då fyller inte det någon långsiktig funko.
Hur ska man tänka när man tar in någon?
Vad är det man ska kravställa?
Vad är det man ska hitta?
Vilka ska man leta efter?
Vad är en bra konsult att leta efter?
Första steget som allt annat är ju att sätta en målbild på vad du faktiskt vill uppnå med det här.
Om du inte ens vet vad konsulten ska bidra med, då ska du absolut inte heller ta in den.
Sen kan det ju vara så att man känner att man inte riktigt vet det.
Så ett sätt att ta reda på det kan ju också vara att om du tar in någon utifrån som ser på din verksamhet, då kan ju det första projektet vara just att ta reda på vart finns det störst potential att utveckla verksamheten genom att lägga ner resurser.
Och i ditt fall som vd, om du sitter med innyttjup och lite kundtjänstmedel och lite alltmedel, då skulle jag ju säga stopp här Joel.
Du är vd för det här företaget.
Din främsta uppgift är ju att se till att ta företaget framåt.
Då kanske inte det är vinnigt att du sitter och skickar ut ett nymmerfrev eller håller på med reklamation.
Då kommer vi till den här uppdelningen av vem som äger den här uppgiften.
Och det här kan nog vara ett bra arbete för väldigt många att göra.
Vad har vi för resurser?
Vem äger det för vad?
Vad är det vi aktivt idag inte gör för att vi inte har tid?
Du kanske känner att vi inte är så dåliga på marknadsföring.
Men varför är vi det?
Lägger vi ingen tid där?
Lägger vi inga pengar?
Vet vi inte vad vi ska göra?
Vad är det som skapar den här känslan av att vi inte är bra?
Sen får man ju någonstans utifrån det försöka se vilken typ av konsult kan det vara som vi behöver ha här?
Vissa roller är ju väldigt mycket tydligare än andra.
Till exempel en CRM-konsult som ska hjälpa dig att kommunicera med befintliga kunder, bygga ut kundbasen, satta upp automatiserade flöden, öka återstryksfrekvensen.
Det är ju ganska tydligt avgransat.
Medans affärsutvecklarverksamheten kan vara lite mer fluffigt.
Hur vet man att man hittar, nu är jag kritisk, det finns jättemånga duktiga konsulter som jag givetvis pratar med, men hur vet man att de är bra?
Vad är det man ska leta efter?
Det där är en väldigt svår fråga.
Det är som att säga om du ska anställa någon, hur vet du att den personen är bra och du vet vilken profil du ska leta efter.
Det är väl kanske en av de största utmaningarna som många har, att du ska anställa en roll, oavsett om det är en konsult eller en fast anställning, inom ett område där du själv inte har någon kunskap.
Då blir det väldigt svårt att avgöra vem som är bra och dålig och också svårt för er att kravställa projektet eller personer.
Så där skulle jag säga att redan där behöver man ju ta hjälp.
Så du ska ta in en konsult för att ta in en konsult?
Åh herregud.
Jag skulle kanske inte ta in en rekryteringskonsult för att ta in en konsult, men det finns ju de företagning som ger vidare den lösningen och det är just för att hjälpa du att matcha ditt kompetensbehov med rätt person.
Men jag tror att många behöver väl ge med läxorna att okej vad är det vi vill förbättra någonting?
Vad är det vi känner att vi inte gör det tillräckligt bra istället för att kanske titta på konkurrenten och försöka att göra det som dem men du vet inte om det de gör är bra eller dåligt.
Och det är väl någonting som jag tror att om vi tänker utsjupeblir dets perspektiv så är det väldigt många som fortfarande idag går fel där.
Man väljer en e-handelsplattform som en konkurrenta så du har ingen aning om den funkar bra för dem eller om dem jobbar på samma sätt som du gör.
Du kanske jobbar på ett helt annat sätt men då är det inte alls det tekniska stöd du ska ha.
Så göra läxan först är mitt råd oavsett, alltså göra en förstudie oavsett om du ska byta en e-handelsplattform, anställa en person eller göra något annat.
Blir man inte bara långsam då, precis som de stora företagen?
Om man gör en förstudie på två år som Elienten gjorde när de skulle byta e-handelsplattform, då blir man väldigt långsam.
Gör man den på en till fyra veckor så skulle jag säga att den tiden du lägger på att göra den här förstudien, de pengarna kommer du att spara in sen på att det blir ett mer effektivt projekt eller en bättre rekrytering sen faktiskt inte du gör det av med efter tre månader och sen ska du börja en ny upplärningsperiod.
Nej, jag fattar det låter väl rimligt.
Skulle vi kunna ta lite grann, nu har du varit i branschen, du sa 12 år men sen när du räknar ihop det så fick jag det till 13.
Så vi säger ett tag i alla fall.
Kan du dela med dig av lite klantgrejer eller lite fuckups som har hänt på vägen där?
Ja, min första sak är väl att hade jag vetat att du var så bra på huvudräkning så hade jag räknat efter mer noggrant.
Nej men det är klart att jag har ju gjort massor av, många skulle kalla det misstag, men jag ser det som lärdomar och varje lärdom du får kommer med ett pris.
Oavsett om du testar olika funktionalitet på din site eller du testar att byta ut ett system, du testar att ändra kontostrukturen eller din kanalmix.
Du vet aldrig om det ska gå bra eller dåligt.
Men oavsett utfallet så har du ju fått en lärdom av att okej så här ska jag göra eller så här ska jag inte göra.
Så jag kan väl...
Vi kommer att klippa bort allt det där fina snacket och så kommer vi bara gå rakt in på missarna.
Jag kan väl ta några som har hänt i närtid.
Jag skulle skicka ut ett mail och skrev ett danskt mail, men skickade det till den svenska kundbasen.
Och det fick förvånansvärt hög öppningsfrekvens faktiskt.
Men när jag insåg det här så tog jag fram ett nytt mail och skickade det även svenskarna då som hade öppnat upp det danska mailet.
Och ämnesraden var typ, ja men din nyfikenhet lönar sig.
Och sen så fanns det en liten förklaring till vad jag hade gjort fel och en rabattkod och öppningsgraden på det mailet var 75 procent.
Jag tror aldrig jag har nått så högt.
Så man kan ju också göra något positivt om något som blev fel.
Så man behöver inte greva 920D.
En annan miss jag har gjort som också fick ett väldigt bra utfall sen var att jag skulle sätta en totalbudget på en brandingkampanj på Google.
Och så när jag skulle gå in och analysera den här kampanjen efter tre dagar, fyra dagar.
Nej, faktiskt efter fem dagar.
Så insåg jag att den här totalbudgeten hade blivit en dagbudget.
Och det blev ju såklart ett väldigt stort stresspåslag.
För vi spenderade ju då såklart sju gånger mer pengar än vad tanken var.
Utfallet blev ju också väldigt positivt och det var ju att försäljningen i oktober det året var liksom all time high.
Så kampanjerna hade ju väldigt positiv effekt.
Sen så blev det ju så att jag fick justera om budgeten för kommande månader för att någonstans spara in de här extra halvmiljonen som jag hade spenderat på en vecka då.
Har du någon fuck up som blev en fuck up?
Ja men de har jag förtränkt.
Det kanske inte är hemligstäppat här, det har inte gått tio år.
Det behöver inte dra då om hon utvill.
Men får jag ta en annan sak, nu egentligen när jag blev pitchad att ha med dig i podden så var det egentligen inte det här jag blev pitchad på, utan då fick jag en annan insikten.
Nu har vi pratat om e-handel lite grann, så jag tänker att alla som vill lyssna på e-handeln, nu ska vi prata om en annan punkt som jag personligen tycker är intressant.
Så ni kan, nu får ni stanna kvar om ni vill.
Men det som jag blev pitchad på var att du hade varit med i en annan podd och så hade du pratat och jag har även lyssnat på det avsnittet.
Och det var en helt vanlig inspelning, alltså det var ett helt vanligt avsnitt.
Men det blev liksom en lite weird händelse av det där.
Skulle du vilja dela med dig av det och berätta vad som hände lite grann?
Ja, byt händerna, absolut.
Jag var med i en podcast och mina arbetsgivare tyckte att jag var alldeles för fyspråkig med vad jag delde med mig av för både bra och dåliga saker.
Vilket gjorde att jag några dagar efter fick sparken.
Men jag som har följt i Andals Community ett väldigt länge, för min uppfattning är att man alltid har varit väldigt bjussig, man har försökt att hjälpa varandra och man har delat väldigt mycket rent generellt.
Så jag gick in med inställningen i den podcasten.
Jag skulle verkligen bidra med mina upplevelser och såklart också försöka att framställa varumärket som framåt lät ut i en kontext där branschen är väldigt old school.
Men vi hade väl egentligen olika tankar om hur mycket information man får dela med sig av.
Och min lärdom av det var ju att även om vi har på papper ett väldigt omfattande yttrandefrihet i Sverige så har du i ditt arbetsgivaravtal, förmodligen en Klaus Uhl som berättar hur du får uttalade om företaget och vad du får, säg och inte säg.
Jag är ju en sådan person som kanske inte lusleser det avtalet eller definitivt inte minst det, fyra år efter jag skriver på det.
Det blev väl en väldigt liksom ett fuck-up som inte skulle vara ett fuck-up.
Men å andra sidan så resulterade det i att jag startade mitt egna företag så med facit i hand så var det väl också ett väldigt bra utfall i det långa locket.
Jag tycker bara att det är intressant eftersom jag tycker att saker ska vara transparent.
Nu har vi inte med så att någon får försvara detta.
Vi pratar om situationen från bara din sida.
Men jag har ju faktiskt lyssnat på det här avsnittet flera gånger, för det är en podd som jag följer och nu finns inte avsnittet kvar.
Men det var ju inte ett konstigt avsnitt.
Det var inte så att du satt och snackade om någonting som inte jag skulle prata om.
Eller jag skulle säga att du hållit tillbaka mer än vad jag pratar om när jag generellt pratar om bolag.
Så det är ingen weird öppning på det sättet.
Dels kan jag tycka att det är synd, för jag upplever också att det som är synd med, i andesfärger det som är bra är de människorna som delar med sig och som är öppna, det är liksom det som är intressant och som driver hela svenska e-handeln framåt på något sätt.
Men det som är tråkigt är när det bara blir massa jävla klichéer och folk säger ingenting utan man säger ja vi ska jobba med en marginal här och vår marginalstruktur.
Det är precis skittråkigt att lyssna på, ingen bryr sig och det betyder ingenting.
Kändes det konstigt att liksom hamna i den situationen med en arbetsgivare där du ändå har jobbat ett tag?
Ni har ju ändå en upparbetad relation, det måste ha känts lite konstigt eller?
Ja, alla som känner mig vet ju att jag ganska ofta har svar på tal, men i den här situationen så var jag faktiskt så kokerad att jag var mållös liksom i det mötet.
Sen så det du beskriver skulle jag säga att det är ju ett problem som går långt bortom i andels varje det här med hur man uttrycker sig idag.
Oavsett om det är en idrottsprofil som gör en intervju eller det är någon annan, så är man så himla rädd om antingen sitt eget varumärke eller det varumärke man representerar.
Man vågar inte riktigt säga sin åsikt för att det finns en risk att du får ett drev efter dig och det drevet kan liksom rasera hela ditt arbetsliv eller ditt privata liv.
Speciellt om du är en mer offentlig person eller faktupsatt inom ett företag.
Det gör ju någonstans att många intervjuer blir väldigt sletstrukna och ger egentligen inget värde att lyssna på.
Sen har vi några personer i världen och Sverige som är lite mer frispråkiga men de får ju också ta väldigt mycket skit.
Jag kan bara tycka att det är sin...
Ja, jag har haft flera personer som skulle varit med i podden men där de har till exempel behövt frågorna i förväg för att de ska kunna lyfta det med sin arbetsgivare.
Och sen har de återkopplat innan intervjun med att jag är ledsen och jag kan inte vara med i podden och prata om det här för jag får inte prata om det här.
Det är lite halvvisart.
Det är inte så att jag frågar efter deras leverantörslista, utan det är ganska enkla, generella frågor.
Och ändå finns det ju det här toppplocket på något sätt som man inte får prata utanför.
Jag vill bara lyfta situationen.
Det är ju tråkigt att du hamnar i den situationen, men som du säger, det är en tråkig situation och det borde ju inte...
Lite bredare borde vi kunna gå kanske.
Ja men här tror jag också att man ser en stor skillnad på nystartade företag och kanske lite mer legacy-företag i hur man tänker kring sådana här delar.
För att om vi tar B2C-varumärken så det som har gjort den framgångsförvika är ju mångt och mycket att de är väldigt inkluderande med sin målgrupp, hur man ska ta vända nya produkter och hur man kommunicerar kring dagliga saker på företaget.
Man är väldigt öppen och transparent.
Och där tror jag att de lite äldre, mindre omoderna företagen är fortfarande ganska byråkratiska och man känner inte en säkerhet och trygghet i sin verksamhet och det gör att man heller inte vill att någon annan ska få veta någonting om den.
Det är i alla fall så min upplevelse är och att i meningen start eller företag så har du företagsledare som är väldigt kompetenta på det som företaget håller på med.
Medan du kanske i andra typer av äldre företag har någon vd som har blivit vd för att han var marknadschef innan eller du har någon som liksom inte kan eller förstår egentligen kärnaffären.
Så det tror jag är en anledning till att det blir så här.
Men i mångt och mycket är det ju den här åsiktskorridoren som i Sverige har varit ganska så omfattande inom väldigt många olika områden.
Vilket är jättetråkigt.
Bara för att någon inte delar i din åsikt så ska du inte förkasta den personen eller förkilla om den personen eller säga att den personen är en klimatförnekare bara för att man inte tycker att vindkraftverk är det bästa på islaget.
Men det är ju tyvärr så det ser ut.
Om jag ska få försvara andra sidan, jag måste lägga två minuter på det då.
Finns det inte en viss logik i det?
Jag kan ju märka att när det bara var jag och Robin på kontoret till exempel, vi hade till exempel lite reklamfilmer där jag sköt honom med paint på olivär.
Nu hade jag väl kunnat göra det idag och de finns kvar.
Vi har ju ändå den.
Men jag kan uppleva att jag är försiktigare i hur jag uttrycker mig.
Nu jämfört med hur jag uttryckte mig för fem, tio år sedan i vår marknadsföring eller vår Instagram.
Jag är ju mycket mer korrekt idag än vad jag var förr.
Då var jag ju väldigt avslappnad.
Det har ju på något sätt hänt saker på vägen.
Jag har fått lite udda hot.
Det är så här konstiga grejer som har hänt på vägen.
Det är folk som inte fattar skämt eller som inte förstår att det här är ju en uppenbart...
Vi har ju uppenbart hittat på den här situationen.
Det här är ju inte på riktigt, det förstår vi.
Men man blir ju ändå lite påverkad av situationen.
Det finns väl ändå en logik i att man som arbetsgivare, ju större man blir, försöker försvara sitt företag från att utsättas för drev eller för negativa saker.
Eller att man avslöjar, jag vet inte, en marginal på någon grej.
Du vet, ska man vara helt, det ska man väl inte.
Det är väl rimligt.
Ja, tyvärr tror jag att det där är en del av vår samtid.
Och det går igen i en väldigt populär kultur, för att idag görs det väldigt lite komedifilmer jämfört med vad det gjordes på början av 2000-talet, alltså American Pie, och det fanns ju jättemycket såhär.
De är ju inte tillräckligt PK idag.
Ingen skulle ens komma på tanken att göra något sånt.
Och det går lite in i det du säger, med att ni gjorde till exempel en jätterolig komisk video för något år sedan kommer jag ihåg, men såhär igenkänningsfaktor på juni.
Ja, just det.
Freudians Lips gjorde vi med.
Idiotiska saker.
Och jag tycker att det är fantastiskt.
Och de som vågar göra det där idag, de kommer att sticka ut ännu mer för att det mycket blir väldigt irritertsägande för att det väcker inget känslor, för att det ska vara väldigt inom ramarna för vad som är okej för alla i hela världen.
Och jag har ett jättebra sånt exempel när det var en franchistagare på Deckskiftarna som postade ett inlägg på TikTok där de gjorde en jätterolig video av att en tjej kom in i butiken när hon hade köpt fälgar och hon sa att jag måste tväla mig tillbaka dem för att min kille tyckte inte om dem.
Han ba okej vi fixar det.
Sedan så beredde han på skärmen och i stället för att ge en ny fälgar så kom det upp en vändning av killar liksom.
Och den här blev tokviral och jättemycket kommentarer.
Men det fanns ju andra franschajstagare som ville att den här skulle ta sig ned omedelbart som kom ifrån kulturer där man absolut inte är okej att en kvinna gör sig rolig på mannens bekostnad.
De hade sin verksamhet i mer invandratetområden.
Där de var väldigt rädda att det här skulle få en backlash på deras verksamhet.
Ja det hade jag nog inte kopplat det som var svårt att göra.
Nej jag hade inte heller gjort det.
Men så det sluter med att det klippet togs bort.
Och jag använder ändå som försvar att det är liksom 700 kommentarer och ingen är negativ.
Det är väl det som ska vara avgörande.
Det är inte någon internpersons åsikt på om det här är bra eller dåligt.
Det är ju faktiskt hur det uppfattas av målgruppen.
Okej det fanns liksom ingen yttre backlash utan det var egentligen en oro internt i den fanne.
Exakt och det är ju det jag menar med att den här interna oron är ju så omfattande i allt.
Det är därför man inte vågar säga vad man tycker i en podd eller i en vill ställa upp.
Det kan ju vara ett reportage intervju eller...
Jag tror att om man är en ägare av en företag som du själv är, så är det ju såklart enklare för att du har ingen annan att svar upp än du själv.
Men det finns ju företagsledare som kanske uttrycker sin åsikt och lite mer där till som blir väldigt hårt bestraffade.
Jag köper det.
Jag tycker att det är en svår diskussion, vi ska inte fastna för mycket.
Men tack för att du delar.
Jag tänker sammanfatta hela det segmentet med att jag borde boka in fler sessioner där jag skjuter Robin med paintball.
Det är liksom det det här gick ut på.
För att stå upp för mänsklighetens framtid.
Förut var ett tal sett inom marknadsföring, om inte din marknadsföringskampanj är så kontroversiell att det blir PR på den om folk ifrågasätter den, då är den inte bra.
Men det där har ju försvinner bort.
Det är ingen som vågar vara kontroversiell idag i princip.
Och PR, om man det så kommer man med något försvarstal till hur man tänker kring den kampanjen.
Jag fattar.
John, stort tack för att du var med i podden.
Jag är väldigt tacksam för att du delar med dig.
Du får ha en underbar dag och så får vi se om vi får någon kommentar om detta.
Så du ska ta in en konsult för att ta in en konsult.
Åh herregud.